interrogation surprise sur le code de la
route
pas si simple après des années de
conduite jeudi dernier 30 participants
se sont prêtés au jeu du rallye moto
touristique à elancourt une journée
organisée par la police nationale
sur place l'ambiance est bon enfant mais
l'enjeu crucial
alors cette journée s'inscrit dans le
cadre d'une action de prévention action
de sensibilisation puisque sur nos
routes comme sur l'ensemble des routes
de au plan national les usagers de
deux-roues paye un très lourd tribut à
l'accidentologie
donc le but de cette journée et les
sensibiliser d'une part aux dangers de
la route mais aussi c'est le but des
ateliers qui est derrière moi
actuellement à la maniabilité à
l'aisance sur leurs motos après un rally
de 80 kilomètres à travers le
département
l'atelier de maniabilité c'est l'ultime
épreuve solidaire la police montre
l'exemple
au programme slalom manoeuvre équilibre
et anticipation une piqûre de rappel
nécessaire avec toutes les associations
qui sont sur place soit sécurité
routière enfin il
les sapeurs pompiers ça nous montre
aussi les dangers on peut rencontrer sur
la route
donc il nous donne pas mal d'indications
aussi sur les les tenues qu'on doit
mettre on ne pas mettre ce qu'on nous
dit pas forcément chez les tous les
revendeurs de d'accessoires auto moto je
trouve ça très intéressant par contre ça
manque
il ya passé deux journées de formation
comme ça d'animation pour que selon moi
ça touche suffisamment de monde et que
les gens comprennent que bah c'est
important de pouvoir maîtriser la moto
sur la route quoi c'est indispensable
on est je pense qu'on est jamais
chevronnés on a toujours des choses à
apprendre et personnellement j'apprends
toujours des choses sur la route
l'opération lancée en 1998 et renouvelée
chaque année dans le département
le dernier bilan de la sécurité routière
dans les yvelines en 2011 enregistre 20
morts de conducteurs de deux roues un
chiffre trop élevé et auquel les
autorités soit mettre un frein